i will now introduce you to the idea of
a homogeneous differential equation
homogeneous
homogeneous it's the same word that we
use for milk when we say that the milk
has been that all the fat clumps have
been spread out but the application here
at least i don't see the connection
homogenous differential equation and
even within differential equations we'll
learn later there's a different type of
homogeneous differential equation those
are called homogeneous linear
differential equations but they they
mean something
actually quite different
but anyway for this purposes we're going
to i'm going to show you how homogeneous
differential equations and what we're
dealing with are going to be first order
equations and what does a homogeneous
differential equation mean well let's
say i had just a a regular
first order differential equation that
could be written like this so
d y
d x
is equal to some function
some function of x and y and let's say
we you know we we try to do this and
it's not separable and it's not exact
what we what we what we learn is that
when we if if it can be homogeneous if
this is a homogeneous differential
equation that we can make a variable
substitution and that variable
substitution allows this quick equation
to turn into a separable one but before
i need to show you that i need to tell
you what does it mean to be homogeneous
well if i can algebraically manipulate
this right side of this equation so that
i can actually rewrite it instead of a
function of x and y if i could rewrite
this differential equation so that d y
d x
is equal to
some function i don't know let's call
that
i don't know we'll call that g
or we'll call it capital f
if i can rewrite it algebraically so
it's a function of y divided by x then i
can make a variable substitution that
makes it that makes it separable so
right now it seems all confusing let me
show you an example so let's say that
let's say that and i'll just show you
the example show you some modules and
then we'll just do the substitution so
let's say that my differential equation
is
d
the the derivative of y with respect to
x
is equal to x plus y
over x
and you can if you'd like you can try to
separate uh make this a separable but
it's not that trivial to solve or at
least i'm looking at inspection it
doesn't seem that trivial to solve and
as we see right here the you know we
have the derivative it's equal to some
function of x and y and my question is
to you can i just algebraically rewrite
this so it becomes a function of y over
x
well sure if we just divide both of
these top terms by x right this this is
the same thing
as
x
over x plus y over x
right this equation is the same thing as
d y over d x is equal to this which is
the same thing as
rewriting this whole equation i'm going
to switch colors arbitrarily as this d y
over dx is equal to x divided by x is
equal to 1 if we assume x doesn't equal
0
plus
y over x so you're probably wondering
what did i mean by a function of y over
x well you can see it here
when i just algebraically manipulated
this equation i got 1 plus y over x so
if i said that y over x is equal to some
third variable i this is just a function
of that third variable and actually i'm
going to do that right now so let's say
let's make a substitution for y over x
so let's say that v
and i'll do v in a different color let's
say that v
is equal to y over x
or another way if you just multiply both
sides by x you could write that y is
equal to
x
v
and we're going to substitute v for y
over x but we're also going to have to
substitute d y over dx so let's figure
out what that is in terms of the
derivatives of v so the derivative of y
with respect to x
is equal to what's the derivative of
this with respect to x well if we assume
that v is also a function of x
then we're just going to use the product
rule so the derivative of x is 1
times v
plus
x times the derivative of v with respect
to x
and now we can substitute this
and this back into this equation and we
get so
d y over dx that is equal to this so we
get
v
plus
x
dv
dx derivative with respect to x is equal
to that's just the left hand side it's
equal to
1 plus y over x but we make we're making
this substitution that v is equal to y
over x is equal to 1 plus v
and now this should be pretty
straightforward so let's see we can
subtract v from both sides of this
equation
subtract v from both sides
and then what do we have left with we
have x dv dx is equal to 1. let's divide
both sides by x and we get the
derivative of v with respect to x is
equal to 1 over x
it should maybe start becoming a little
bit clear what the solution here is but
let's just keep going forward so
if we multiply both sides by dx we get
dv is equal to 1
over x times dx
now we can take the antiderivative of
both sides
integrate both sides
and we're left with
v
is equal to
the natural log
of the absolute value of x
plus c
and we are kind of done but it'd be nice
to get this solution in terms of just y
and x and not have this third variable v
here because our original problem was
just in terms of y and x
so let's do that what was v
we made the substitution that v is equal
to y over x so let's reverse substitute
it now or unsubstitute it so we get y
over x
is equal to the natural log
of x
plus c some constant multiply both sides
times x and you get y
is equal to x times the natural log
of x
plus
c
and we're done we solved that that
seemingly inseparable
differential equation by recognizing
that it was homogeneous and making that
variable substitution v is equal to y
over x that termed it into a separable
a separable equation in terms of v and
then we solved it and then we
unsubstituted back and we got the
solution to the differential equation
you can verify it for yourself that y is
equal to the x natural log of the
absolute value of x plus c oh actually i
made a mistake y over x is equal to the
natural log of x plus c if i multiply
both sides of this equation times x
what's the solution it's not just x
natural log of x it's it's i have to
multiply this times x 2 right i multi
distributive property that was a that
was an amateur mistake so the correct
solution is y is equal to x natural log
of the absolute value of x plus
x times c
and if you wanted to figure out c i
would have to give you some initial
conditions and then you could solve for
c and that would be the particular
solution then for this differential
equation in the next video i'll just do
a couple more of these problems i'll see
you then